today's topic uh someone asked abba do
you feel like you're fostering
uh a toxic community and i was like why
do you say that it's like because i look
at your comment section it's
terrible and i said okay so what do you
see like well i see a lot of guys
who just seem like they don't like women
very much i was like
okay i was thinking about this i thought
i've been thinking about this for a
minute right
do the comments necessarily reflect the
content creators intentions and do you
have a responsibility and this is what
i'll say
our views get what 600 000 people
seven hundred thousand people how much
comments do we get
five thousand so is that five thousand
really a reflection
of how everyone is or or
the people is it the most loud and most
angry who take time to write in a
youtube comment
i don't know but i'm not going to let
that comment section and all the crazy
stuff i sometimes read in there
cloud my judgment of how our people are
viewing us the people i meet on the
street the people who hit us up in the
dms on a general basis
super cool generally kind of people i
don't look to youtube comment sections
to find out what's going on with society
i get there's funny stuff in there
i get there's a whole bunch of
opinionated people but youtube
comment sections should not be where you
look for as a referendum
of the psyche of the content creators
and things like that we could make a
mild video i could
make a video where i'm like hey you know
what ladies i understand that you want a
six-figure man but i also understand
because men want different dating
standards you might struggle a little
bit
very reasonable stance right men have
different needs than women cool we all
agree
cool guys get in the comments he's like
yeah that [ __ ] was tricks and but bro i
didn't say all that
but why is there that connection between
what i said
and what they're saying why are they
saying all that because men have never
seen their issues reflected for so long
and they've had pent up frustration from
so much
happening and it never being addressed
that even the minute
content addressing some of their issue
makes them want to
flood everything it doesn't even address
it yeah it just
grazes it not even touching it and
because it's the closest thing
the closest thing that meteorite didn't
even land on her
but this is the closest thing to the
light that passed
so they're going to latch on to that
remember when the meet you uh movement
happened right
let me meet you mimi today's video is
sponsored oh wait
all right you already know okay we're
ready today's video is sponsored by blue
chew say it with us now blue chip it's
time for you to gain more
confidence and longer lasting
experiences
in the bedroom with bluetooth tablets
okay you deserve better
she deserves harder get it together
bars listen bluechu is a unique online
service
that offers you the same active
ingredients
as a viagra in cialis but in a chewable
form
and at a fraction of the cost and one of
the best parts is that you know
bluetooth
it's an online service so you don't need
to go to the doctor and have an awkward
conversation with that person
all you gotta do is go to bluetooth.com
you just need to consult with one of
their medical licensed professionals
and once you're approved we just ship it
to your door and we got a special deal
just for you guys
you can try bluetooth for free when you
use promo code abba
all right and all you gotta do is pay
for the five dollar shipping that's
bluechew.com using promo code abba and
get your first month
free so a big shout out to bluetooth for
sponsoring this video right remember
when that movement happened right there
was a whole flood of women just coming
for the experiences
and there was some crazy talk too men
are all
this men are all perpetrators made of
all men
but i want to ask when women were
bringing forth their story and they were
being handed
and then there were some people who were
going crazy in the comments and saying
all wow about dudes was that a
reflection of the content
or was it the fact that folks have been
having a build up for
so long that once this opened the
floodgates
avalanche you're having crazy sentiments
extreme stuff
constantly i question that here's why i
feel like
i haven't always done a good job there
have been certain videos that i looked
down like
yeah we didn't cover that well or we
weren't fair and balanced or
we went a little bit too far and you
know that's the nature of the beast
i accept that i've made mistakes and i
need to do better and i constantly try
to improve on the future video that's
right you need to do better right but i
think you cannot discount the big thing
which is the fact that as a group men
have feel like their issues have been
ignored for
so long and as a result they are lashing
out everywhere
i'm not saying you have to tolerate it
i'm not saying it's necessarily a good
thing i'm saying
this is not a reflection of me this is a
reflection of what men are dealing with
as a whole on a large platform
that's what i'm trying to say so yeah as
far as the comment section go i'm not
proud of it i don't always love it but
what do you want me to do you know when
i when i do a video where we're just
like having a laugh and doing a couple
like roasts
i've seen some people men and women who
will go
to the original content creator who may
have just said something awkward
and they'll say foul things to them i
have never once endorsed
someone going up to another content
creator and saying some terrible stuff
i've never once encouraged that
never not even people but people still
do it i can't control how people act
online yep
i can't right there's a 1.2 million with
all kinds of different lived experiences
and childhoods and all that
i can't control that i can say i don't
do that kind of stuff and i don't
encourage it
but i can't control what individuals on
the internet do so does it keep me out
of that
no i try to be better but beyond that
i'm just like it is what it is
you know i think talking about these
issues and being honest and truthful for
the vast majority of people who can
consume this content and not have issues
is what i'm here for
that's my thoughts you have this
conversation with someone
was asking me oh i was in an interview
and someone with that that person
they're asking me yeah so
how does how was it to have all this you
know this fame and these people loving
you and i'm like
every day i wake up in the morning and i
say i ain't just to bring me down to the
level and just to just you know hey
all this can go away and i'm just a
normal human being
right i ain't special i'm just a normal
human being so i don't really
necessarily take everything like all the
oh great i love you guys so much you're
my favorite youtube
i don't i appreciate it but i don't
necessarily take it for cash
it doesn't mean that people love what i
do that i'm actually doing great
so i'm always reminding myself of that
yeah and then she goes on in the
interview
we go on we talk about different stuff
yeah and then she goes
uh i like what you do but you guys are
dislike women yeah
that term and i'm like how how is it how
is it
where if you're if you're gonna call me
something right as serious as that
boo boo honey chicken cherry chocolate
bunny a bunch of slices i'm in a cherry
on top you better bring facts
bring me something some facts some
substance that backs up what you're
saying
i'm like so where where where and then
she starts stumbling and i'm like wow
girl
you're adrenaline some journalists you
are that question
messed you up where well well well and
she resorted to the comment well if
i look at your comments your comment
section looks like this and that
and some people say pretty harsh words
hey
remember when i was talking we were
talking about the compliments and we
will talk about how i received the
compliments well the positive things
and the negative things i keep the same
energy
i don't take it too seriously it doesn't
necessarily mean anything
but those people making those comments
or prop negative comments are probably
acting out of
emotion the same way you're acting in
emotion
and in your brain you said the comments
are like that it's under there you
didn't think
you said there then therefore they are
you
and the people commenting have the same
ammo
you guys are not that different you're
the same people
but you're on the different side of the
spectrum which the different side of the
spectrum
especially is not like this by the way
it's not a band it's a circle
the other side of the circle the circle
is right there
y'all guys are sitting next to each
other she didn't like that
but it's still what it is so the same
way i don't take really
thank you for the positive comments but
i don't really take it out of cash
and it doesn't define what i'm doing or
who i am because i
can go all the way really fast and it
doesn't mean i'm gonna
i'm doing a good job or the negative
comments as well
how you take it the same way that
[ __ ] took what i took
and you're doing the same thing so
yeah yeah
it don't mean anything it's comments i
detach myself from the comments i take
it
i take what i gotta take and i leave
what i gotta leave i hope you should do
the same thing too
and you have to understand as well that
you know the human brain the way the
human brain functions
we focus a lot more on negative
than positive most of the comments are
positive yeah you know what you're going
to fixate on the negative ones
yeah you know what makes me think of
it's like i fix it on a negative one as
well sometimes
it's like political polls they're like
well this is what the polls say i'm like
well
who's volunteering to do these posts
where did you ask
where did you choose the people yep that
could change a lot of things yeah like
you said
the polls it's like the polls are the
comment section so out of 600
000 people watching the video your poll
was 5 000 people
and you just took the worst out of the 5
000 people commenting
maybe there's a different different
psyche involved in people who decide to
leave comments
there's a whole bunch of different
factors you got to consider so it's a
terrible representation you know what
it's like
it's like people who spend their whole
lives online right and they're like oh
my god
you know q and r and all these they're
so terrible then they go in real life
and try to talk to this with strangers
like
what is that i've never heard of that
group most people are not in that bubble
so whatever reality that you've painted
for yourself it's not necessarily real
so yeah those are my thoughts anything
else
cool leave your comments
[Music]
foreign